Welcome to the second
presentation on functions.
So let's take off where
we left off before.
I still apologize -- in
retrospect that that
whole foul food example.
Well maybe it was helpful, so
I'm going to leave it there.
Let's do some more problems.
I think the best thing is to
keep doing problems with you
and I think you'll see the
example, and hopefully
you'll actually see that
functions are kind of fun.
Let's do some more problems.
Let's start off with an
example, not too different
than what we saw before.
Let's say that g of x is
equal to 1 if x is even, and
it equals 0 if x is odd.
And let's say f of x is equal
to x plus 3 times g of x.
And let's say -- I'm going to
make it really complicated --
well, actually I'm not going
to make it any more
complicated now.
So let's try some problems.
So let's give an example.
What is f of 5.
Well, it's really pretty
straightforward.
We take this 5 and we replace
it for x in the function f.
So f of 5 is equal to 5 plus
3 times g of 5, right?
We just literally took this
5 and replace it everywhere
where we see an x.
If instead of a 5, I had like a
dog here, it would be f of dog
would equal dog plus
3 times g of dog.
Not that that would necessarily
make any sense, but
you get the idea.
So f of 5 equals 5
plus 3 times g of 5.
But what does that equal?
So the 5 stays the same, plus 3
times -- well what's g of 5?
Well, if we put 5 here,
if 5 is even we do 1,
if five is odd we do 0.
Well 5 is odd so it's a 0.
So g of 5 is equal to 0.
So this is 3 times 0.
So this equals just 5,
right, because 3 times
0 is equal to 5.
Well what would be f of 6?
Well, f of 6 would equal
6 plus 3 times g of 6.
And once again, that equals 6
plus -- well, this time g of
6 is, well, 6 is even, so 1.
So g of 6 is equal to 1.
So this equals 6
plus 3 times 1.
So this equals 6 plus
3 which equals 9.
I think you might be
getting the idea now.
At first when you see a problem
with a lot of these functions,
it seems very confusing.
But if you just keep taking
what's inside of the
parentheses and replacing that
for x and just keep moving
along that way, you make a lot
of progress on these problems.
Let's try a harder one.
Let's say I said that f of x
is equal to x squared plus 1.
Let's say that g of x is equal
to 2x plus f of x minus 3.
And h of x is equal to 5x.
Now I'm going to give
you a tough problem.
What is h of g of x?
No.
What is h of g of -- let's
pick a number -- let's say 3?
h of g of 3.
Actually, we'll do examples in
the future where we actually
could leave the x there
and we'll solve for it.
But let's say this particular
example, what is h of g of 3?
At first you might say wow,
this is crazy, Sal, I don't
know how to even start here.
But you just take
it step-by-step.
What can we figure out?
Can we figure out
what g of 3 is?
Well sure.
We could take the 3 and put
it into the function g and
see what it spits out.
So let's work on g of 3 first.
So, g of 3 equals -- well it's
2 times 3, right, we're just
replacing wherever we
see an x with a 3.
So it's 2 times 3, so that's
6, plus f of -- what, we'll
just replace the x again.
3 minus 3, right?
So this g of 3 is equal
to 6 plus f of what?
3 minus 3 is 0.
Now we have to figure
out f of 0 is.
We have a definition here for
f, so we just figure it out.
f of 0 is equal to -- well,
you replace the 0 here.
So you get 0 squared,
which is 0 plus 1.
So it's f of 0 is 1.
So you take that and you
replace it for f of 0.
So you get g of 3 is
equal to 6 plus 1.
So g of 3 is equal to 7, right?
Now we know what g
of 3 is equal to.
We can substitute
that back here.
So that's the same thing -- we
know g of 3 is equal to 7,
so that's the same
thing as h of 7.
And h of 7 is just equal
to 5 times 7 equals 35.
So I think you're probably a
little confused here, and I
would have been if I
was in your shoes.
But the important thing is when
you first see this problem
you're like what can
I tackle first?
h of g of 3, it seems
very confusing.
Well, g of 3, can
I tackle that?
Sure.
I have a definition of what
the function g does when
it's given an x, or in
this case, was given a 3.
And that's what we did.
We figured out what
g of 3 was first.
And g of 3, we just have to do
the 3, and we said well that's
6 plus f of 3 minus 3, right?
Because we just replaced
that x with that 3.
And we just kept solving.
We figured out what
f of 0 is up here.
And we got g of 3 equals 7.
Then we substituted that
back in right here.
We got h of 7 is equal to 35
because it was 5 times 7.
Let's do some more problems.
Actually, let's do another
example with the same
set of functions.
I don't want to keep confusing
you with new functions.
Let me it erase this
as fast as I can.
I think I'm getting faster
at this erasing business.
You can sit and think a little
bit about what we just
did while I erase.
So let's do another problem.
What is f of h of 10?
Well, first we want to figure
out what h of 10 is, right?
Well, we could do it
in a different way
as we'll see later.
But we can figure out what
h of 10 is pretty easily.
We take the 10,
substitute it in for x.
h of 10 is equal to 5 times x.
In this case x is 10
so it equals 50.
So we know h of 10 equals 50.
So we know h of 10 equals
50, so we substitute
that back in here.
So we say f of h of 10 is
the same thing as f of 50.
And then f of 50 is, I think
pretty straightforward
at this point.
You just take that 50 and
replace it back here.
Well, it's 50 squared plus 1.
Well, 50 squared
is 2,500 plus 1.
That equals 2,501.
What is g of h of 1?
Well, we take h of 1, h of 1 is
5, so this is equal to g of 5.
And g of 5, we just replace the
5 here, so g of 5 is equal to 2
times 5 plus f of 5 minus 3.
We just take wherever we saw
an x and replace it with a 5.
Well, that's equal to 2 times
5 is 10, plus f of 5 minus 3.
Well 5 minus 3 is 2.
Plus f of 2.
What's f of 2?
Well, 2 squared plus 1 is
5, right? f of 2 is 5
-- 2 squared plus 1.
So that equals 10 plus
5 which equals 15.
If you're still
confused, don't worry.
I'm about to record some more
problems that will give you
even more examples of
function problems.
See you in the next
presentation.
Bye.